common rank-and-file Mexican citizens
have an enormous skepticism and
suspicion of government because all
they've seen is a government that's
incapable my name is Sam Kenny honest
I'm reporter author I write now for the
Los Angeles Times well the books really
have the same theme almost and that is
that people can and have in Mexico
escaped that suffocating paternalistic
central government embrace and gone out
and done things on their own one story
was about an entire village where
everyone became popsicle maker and and
their shops are all across Mexico in the
thousands they're not really a franchise
that's more like a business model or
idea that's just been put into practice
over and over and over but all on their
own by guys who were just like Ranchero
types you know and poor guys who didn't
know that they had any business ability
whatsoever until they actually showed
themselves what they did of course the
second book is Antonio's gun and
delfino's Dream is all about immigrants
and immigrants gosh that's that's
exactly their story is I'm I'm upset
with the way things are here I could
wait around for someone else to change
it for me or I could see if things will
change doesn't look like they will so
what can I do well I can use what I have
which isn't much in this world it's only
kind of gumption Drive desire to kind of
do anything to get ahead and and vote
with my feet and of course millions and
millions for 60 years plus now have been
doing that
the pre the Institutional Revolutionary
Party which ran Mexico for 70 plus years
was really the most successful of the
20th century as many one party states
because it achieved all that it did that
rule that that control that that the the
maintaining control over Mexico without
really utilizing secret police to any
great extent no gulags no tanks on the
streets most the time anyway it was more
of a party that was based on the idea
that every person had his price you know
and in a poor country that wasn't really
too high and so over and over throughout
history you see millions and millions of
examples of how the pre would co-opt
movements people that's why the the own
on the University in Mexico City had for
a while
four hundred and fifty thousand students
right fifty five thousand professors to
just keep everyone kind of contained you
know it was this as big buy off
essentially and corruption was the
lubricant it was not some human failing
I write in the first book it was not a
humane failing that we you see it
normally it was the lubricant it was
essential to the system and that's how
the system worked and that's part of
Mexico's problem today is that that's
still they've still having tremendous
difficulty getting over that legacy
there was this rather strange very
definitely bizarre eventually
excommunicated Catholic priest who set
up his own cult or a little kind of
community in the middle of the the
tierra caliente which is a particularly
violent part of the state of Michoacan
not far from Mexico City and there this
man kind of ruled over this town
and there were rapes there was child
molestation there was a lot of bringing
people in selling them property and then
throwing them off the property
all of this was definitely against the
law and they did not allow anyone to
walk into the town I tried this several
times now obviously Mexican Constitution
allows for free transit across the
country but this guy's name was Pablo
down below his place was called New
Jerusalem this little community was able
to function outside the law because
every election they voted everybody in
the entire town voted for the priest so
anybody who was running against the Prix
in that little district had
automatically to overcome a 1200 vote
margin it so happened that the very day
that I was able to walk into New
Jerusalem was that was there there All
Saints Day and everybody in the town has
a saint and it's not just like in normal
times where you just have you're saying
you kind of think it's a good thing okay
everybody dresses up on that day as
their saint and so all around this
village where people walking around
looking like Moses like Prince's out of
the Renaissance people with it halos
built out of made out of you know
clothes hangers long flowing dresses it
was if as if the whole town had walked
into an open-air insane asylum that
whole story I wrote it really based on
the idea that this was how the pre
co-opted this one little part but if you
multiply that across the across the
Mexico you understand how the pre was
able to stay in power
I wrote a story about the town of
Southgate which is southeast of Los
Angeles an area that's now famous or
infamous for being the home Abell where
all the salaries were way out of whack
and all that kind of thing but Southgate
was really the first example of just
rampant and brazen outrageous corruption
among city local governments the town of
South Gate was run very quickly into
bankruptcy by some very unscrupulous
people and tell I'll write all about it
on my story but the attitude was the kid
that allowed that to happen was directly
out of Mexico which was politics or
something we don't get involved in we
don't know what's in City Hall except
for police officers we don't to be
involved with them that's not our what
we're here for the corrupt politicians
in Southgate
understood who their voters were and
they began to use a number of this of
the tactics that the pre used mainly
giving away stuff by the time I came
upon it they had an enormous toy
giveaway in this huge parking lot three
four thousand toys big rides clowns
tacos a whole bit and then at the end by
the end they literally they gave away a
house they gave away a house that the
city owned it with five hundred thousand
dollar piece of gift to someone they
raffled it off to give to somebody it
was totally a gift of public property
totally illegal and never happened in
the long run but but at the time it was
all about if we give people stuff they
will they will vote for us
I went to Mazatlan to do a story really
about beauty queens I just thought it
was fascinating in this town was
obsessed with beauty queens there's a
beauty queen for almost everything
restaurant soccer leagues fire fighters
little leagues you know on and on part
of that somebody told me that there was
a gay beauty contest as well that I
should check out and so I went out there
really not intending to spend any more
than a you know a day or two there
trying to figure it all out and ended up
spending eight weeks combined virtually
living with this little colony of drag
queens as they prepared for what was
going to what was then the oldest drag
queen beauty contest in Mexico all
across Mexico you would see drag queens
and now in the United States you see
them like in the urban centers in the
Tenderloin in San Francisco or in
Greenwich Village in New York or
wherever it is right but here in Mexico
you would see them everywhere that out
in the middle of nowhere little rent
little rural areas guys would get on
with halter tops and pick them plucked
eyebrows near my house in Mexico City
every Friday night there'd be these
enormous gorgeous guys with you know six
foot three and Adam's apples and and
they'd be out there you know hooking on
the street corner so I the question was
why is it that the country that's so
macho have so many guys dressed up like
women right you know what I came to
understand was that it's because Mexico
was such a macho country that there's so
many guys dressed up as one because you
don't dare recognize your own natural
homosexuality by sleeping or having sex
with a man dressed as a man particularly
not especially not I would say this is
where it really is true in the lower say
three quarters of the economic scale of
Mexico the poorest two-thirds of
three-quarters of the population that is
just you want that plausible deniability
oh I was drunk oh she looked really like
a girl oh I didn't know what I was doing
you know through it I came to understand
that that that these guys were necessary
to Mexico and without a my you know you
kind of feared what might happen some
kind of an immense social eruption
explosion because they didn't have the
whole toast to kick around
the migration of Mexicans to the United
States is clearly the most important
migration of any people from one country
to another in the last hundred years of
course they are the word they are a huge
part of our working class now and you
see this not just anymore in Kansas in
California or Arizona or Texas but all
across the country and they at times
that have saved areas in parts of Kansas
I was in would would be dead were it not
for for their labor
avoir often thought that economists
ought to use Mexican immigrants as
economic barometers the way they you
know real estate sales are up all that
kind of stuff our Mexican populations up
you know that ought to be a matter of of
economic well-being because Mexicans do
not go where there are no jobs the
reason we have all those jobs
the reason the economics works is
because though I think in large part is
because of this real egalitarian sense
of that we have that we put in place and
put in enshrined in law and in culture
and tradition and that's what I think a
lot of times immigrants respond to
especially when they come here they come
here with this idea I'm going to make
some money sent at home is kind of thing
but what they actually end up doing is
seeing how much they can be sounds like
a you know army commercial or something
like that be all you can be able to come
to the United States and you will show
you all you can all you can be and
that's a beautiful story to write that's
so amazing I see it over and over and
over all these folks come here and have
the veil kind of lifted
you know Mexico loses an enormous amount
when that happens because it's not that
these folks always send home money 26
billion a few years ago I think it's
down to 23 now for this year or
something like that maybe twenty two
billion it's it still doesn't even make
come close to making up for the loss of
dynamic young blood
Mexico has has spent centuries building
up its central apparatus it's government
in the center its mindset that the
central government knows best etc and
the great tragedy of Mexico today
the great catastrophe of Mexico today is
that it has no local institutions worth
the name you can see it in ciudad juarez
field at juarez is a town that has tons
of growth and almost no development
alright there's vast shanty towns
there's no because the city is drained
of all its tax revenue and it's sent
down to mexico city and only a little
bit comes back not anything commensurate
with the need fascinating to see the
homicide statistics if you compare
forests in El Paso or any other Mexican
city on the border and it's its sister
city across the border
you know Horace has had 3,000 murders I
think in the last two-and-a-half years
or something like some colossal amount I
can't have lost count I try not to count
anymore honestly El Paso I think has had
like maybe 60 or 80 or something like
that why because they we have developed
strong vibrant agile well-funded really
important local government here and that
keeps a lot of that stuff out you know
and and that's what next
member